:
le parc olympique vient d'ouvrir
de nouvelles installations
au pied du stade.
Et c'est gratuit.
Jacques Bissonnet s'y est rendu.
- Une piste à obstacles au pied
de la Tour olympique
de Montréal, à la grande joie
des planchistes.
GABRIEL, planchiste
- Avant, il n'y avait pas
vraiment d'options dans la
Ville. Il fallait que
tu sortes de la Ville,
comme aller à St-Bruno,
à St-Sauveur ou à Bromont.
Là, c'est cool. T'sais, c'est
un accès pour tout le monde.
C'est gratuit.
- Cette nouvelle piste se trouve
sur les lieux même de l'ancienne
piste de ski Morgan,
très populaire au siècle dernier
avec son remonte-pente
et aussi sa grande glissoire
en bois.
CÉDRIC ESSIMINY, Parc olympique
- Il y a plus d'une centaine
d'années, bien, les jeunes
se donnaient rendez-vous ici,
sur la côte Morgan, pour
pratiquer les sports de glisse.
- Ce projet a été réalisé
grâce à un partenariat
entre la Fondation Dillon Ojo,
la compagnie Vans Canada
et le parc Olympique.
Elaine Charles est la mère de
Dillon Ojo, un jeune planchiste
montréalais de 22 ans mort
accidentellement en 2018.
ELAINE CHARLES,
fondation Dillon Ojo
- Quelqu'un qui est
un planchiste, d'avoir ça
dans sa ville, que ses amis
peuvent participer, c'est...
- C'est un rêve.
- C'est un rêve. Un rêve
de parent pour notre enfant
puis un rêne pour Dillon.
ALEX AUCHU, directeur marketing,
Vans Canada
- On a travaillé avec
des experts pour le design
du parc. C'est sûr que c'est
un sport qui peut comporter
certains dangers, mais c'est
obligatoire de mettre un casque,
etc. Puis, il faut s'écouter
là-dedans, hein. Il faut y aller
à notre rythme.
- Une autre belle occasion
d'aller jouer dehors
en ces temps de pandémie.
PIERRE-OLIVIER, planchiste
- Moi, c'est pour ça que je suis
ici. On est confinés chez nous,
on ne peut pas vraiment sort